foreign
when I saw this article I I said okay
okay I gotta show this to Dave I read it
it says nearly half of young adults in
the U.S are living at home with their
parents and all that saved money on rent
is fueling a luxury boom
it says a record number of young adults
in the U.S are currently living at home
and all that saved money is sparking a
luxury boom that's unbelievable to me
because if you read down in the article
it says 48 of these young adults are
living with their parents this is 20
this is in 2022 so this is not like
from 2020 right we know that people kind
of hold up together because of the
pandemic in 2020 but it's still taking
place and it says that
it's because they have all this extra
money and instead of paying off I don't
know they're debt this is a historical
High since the Great Depression yeah
these numbers have not been seen since
the Great Depression 48 so let me get
this straight you live in your mama's
basement but you got a Coach purse you
got a Coach purse and and these these
companies that are you know they make
Tiffany and Dior and Hennessy and all
these luxury Brands they saw a 20 Spike
above and they're contr they're
attributing it to baby children from
baby children and at first Dave I'll be
honest when I when I first read this my
my anger and my frustration was at the
Young Adult
but then I thought about it I thought
about it more and I said no no no no
this is a helicopter mama got out of
control helicopter Daddy got out of
control helicopter Mom this is also you
know it's a result in my mind
it's three things it's the parenting
right we've sent that message that
basically we're going to do everything
we're not parenting this is coddling cod
we've coddled the confidence right out
of these people we've coddled it right
that's tweetable think about it when
you've got parents who say I don't trust
that you can do this I don't trust that
you can make it out there on your own I
don't trust that you can use your
god-given intellect and skill to earn
money and pay rent why don't you come
back and live here and oh by the way
when you live here we'll cook your meals
we'll pay your rent you know if you need
a little gas for money we'll give you
that too then Dave you've got the
government saying hey you can't pay for
your student loans we'll do it for you
and then you've got this this mixture of
then now social culture telling you
everything you everything you say is
Right everything you think is right you
can do no wrong now tell me Dave how
does that create an adult who can go in
and function in society what this is
creating is uh for the particular young
people that are falling pray for it
is what's known as a train wreck it's a
train wreck you described a train wreck
because here's what's going to happen
you cannot avoid life you can't
it's coming for your butt well that's
what's happened and mama can't protect
you and Biden can't protect you nope and
your opinion doesn't matter until you've
got actual experience to base that
opinion on that's right but the world
has 22.
I really don't care what your opinion is
I know that's right and they're getting
out into the world and they're going
wait a minute this this is different
well the problem is when they do get in
the world and they will they will
they're going to run into reality which
reality says truthfully reality says you
are not an expert on something just
because you breathe air
your opinion is not valid that's right
unless it is based on some kind of facts
that were based on not feelings that's
right but you've been told that your
feelings are all valid and they are
valid feelings yeah but anybody that
leads their life by feelings is known as
a child adults devise a plan and follow
it children do what feels good that's
right here's here's who we need to rant
at and you're exactly right Rachel Cruz
said this 10 years ago or 15 years ago
the first time we don't have a student
loan crisis we have a parenting it's
parenting it's parenting and I say it
all the time you have to you can't
absorb everything for your kids now I've
got young kids Dave I got two-year-olds
and you send them to the salt mines
every morning
it's very easy to want to step in and
not let them
fail not let them feel disappointment
not let them feel hurt you gotta let
them feel it here's the problem when
you're a parent that you think you are
doing your child a favor by making it
easy for them you're in actually making
it harder for them because you're stupid
well you're seeing a message that you
think that they're not going to have to
learn the lesson they have to learn
lessons so you're better off to learn
the lesson while at home and 15 years
old and feel the pain of calluses on
your hands feel the pain of actual
discipline and responsibility at a
reasonable level where I can protect you
from it being crushing pain that's right
as your dad but I'm gonna make sure that
you feel the abrasion so that when you
feel real abrasion later real adversity
later you've got the freaking character
to stand in the wind and the resilience
because if you don't allow that you're
again you're sending that message I
don't have have confidence in you and
there's an undercurrent that the child
feels that okay I I can't do this so
then when they do get out in the world
and all those things happen they don't
know how to they don't know how to be
resilient they don't know how to handle
it because they have not had to build
that level of confidence and like you
said character and it's just I gave this
example the other day I was talking
about my kid and um you know he wants to
help me set the table at night and look
he's he's four years old he's not going
to do it right he's going to put the
stuff on the edge of the table probably
Gonna Knock the glass off it's going to
break all these things and I it's a
great opportunity for me to step in and
go you know I'll just do it I'll put it
like this I know how to do it but if I
do that I'm telling him I don't have
confidence in you to either do it right
and I certainly don't have confidence in
you to make a mistake and learn from it
there's no dignity there's no dignity
there when you are coddled you gotta let
them do it there is no dignity when you
have no autonomy because you have
absolutely no actual skills that's right
and by the way managing in your social
media account is not a social it's not a
skill
okay that you don't qualify for that one
okay that one doesn't count you don't
get making comments on other people's
actual achievements is not a skill yeah
that's not an achievement you didn't
achieve anything when you did that yeah
and so when you live in your mother's
basement and you write a blog on
Personal Finance the rest of the world
laughs at you yeah and your mommy thinks
you're cute so a message to these young
adults living at home you've been
enabled we're telling you you've been
enabled you have been coddled you have
been put in a situation that is not for
your best interest now it is time for
you to do something to change that
it's time for you to get up it's time
for you to get out the problem is not I
can't afford rent that is a symptom the
problem is you've got debt you're not
earning enough money and you're not
doing enough to go out and change it Mom
and Dad can't do this for you and don't
blame it on the fact that folks are
getting married later in life no that's
that's right because that's a whole
other thing no it's not it's look work
more go to the bar less
was that was that okay that that's it
because you took your you took your beer
pong skills from college and you brought
them home to your 23 year old self and
you converted them to happy hour skills
yeah and so we live from Thank God It's
Friday to oh God it's Monday and this is
the recipe for freaking failure so if
you're a young person listening to us we
are not picking on you we are begging
you to get away from your parents
they're stupid they did they did you
wrong and parents if you're listening in
the New Year it's time for you to serve
a notice that's the gift the gift that
they need to open up is a a pink slip
yep you got toast you got till March you
got till June no more than June June's
Max but uh I mean give them give them an
exit ramp give them an on-ramp give them
an off ramp whatever you want to call it
but let's lay out a game plan coach them
help them show them what to do and let
me just tell you a eagle that does not
leave the nest is eventually known as a
turkey
they are useless you do not want to be
38 and living in your mother's basement
by the way young men uh no woman wants
to date you because you're what's known
as a wuss
you are not eligible you are not
eligible you look like a parasite you do
not look like a person who can carry
half of a relationship oh my goodness my
daughter I wish my daughter would bring
home a dude that's living in his parents
basement oh big Sam be lighting that guy
up
all right
hey seriously folks love your children
well enough
cause them to grow up that's right and
out